[Musique]
oui
institute of advanced studies princeton
1949 einstein bien encore traverser le
couloir et demandé au camp dial von
neumann de bien vouloir baisser le
volume de son grammophon si einstein et
met longuement et profondément méditer
certains problèmes ésotérique von
neumann était une machine à calculer à
se remémorer et à créer des nouvelles
mathématiques
tel un rouleau compresseur von neumann
semblait s'être intéressé à tous et
avoir complètement révolutionné toutes
les disciplines qui ont la chance de
l'intéressé en mathématiques il a touché
à tout nos ensembles aux opérateurs en
mesure à la géométrie autre ailier aux
automates cellulaires aux équations aux
dérivées partielles et bien plus encore
les doigts pts et leur disait de lui
qu'en mathématiques il a contribué à
tous sous domaines à l'exception de la
théorie des nombres et de la topologie
et ça je pense c'est quelque chose
d'unique
mais la marque de fabrique de von
neumann à nos sens c'est surtout d'avoir
fait complètement explosé le domaine des
mathématiques appliquées en montrant
encore et encore que les mathématiques
pouvait révolutionner des domaines où on
pourrait les pensées inutile monomane
aura ainsi ajouter des pierres
angulaires à la mécanique quantique à
l'hydrodynamique à la mécanique
statistique quantique mais aussi à
l'architecturé informatique
anticipant ainsi le fonctionnement des
ordinateurs modernes à la programmation
linéaire
anticipant ainsi l'optimisation des
processus industriels à l'étude de
l'auto réplication anticipant ainsi la
structure biologique de l'adn à
l'énergie contre yb en alors notamment
au projet manhattan et ensuite à la
commission pour l'énergie atomique à la
météorologie anticipant notamment les
modèles prédictifs qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui à la climatologie anticipant
notamment la théorie du réchauffement
climatique à la simulation numérique
anticipant notamment de l'importance des
méthodes de monte carlo et des nombreux
pseudo aléatoires à la neuroscience
anticipant ainsi le vaste domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle
bref ce mec sain
très nombreux sont ses contemporains qui
ont été impressionnés par son génie pour
ceux qui n'en sont pas convaincus je
recommande très vivement sa page
wikipédia notamment la section
cognitives et abilities de sa page
anglophone mais bien sûr dans le cadre
de cette série sur démocratie ce sur
quoi je veux m'attarder à la
contribution monumentale de valmagne à
l'économie en particulier le livre free
world games and economic review coécrit
avec morgenstern monomane étant alors au
sommet de sa réputation
ce livre fit sensation le prestigieux
new york times n'hésita pas à en faire
la une de son journal des étudiants de
princeton surnommé rapidement la bible
et la marines des états unis investi des
millions dans la recherche initié par
von neumann koungheul chapelet et au
coeur n'était que quelques-uns des
grands mathématiciens qui vénérait re de
travail de monomane enfin l'économie a
été le pouvoir reposer sur des
fondations mathématiques solides à
l'instar de la physique
trois siècles plus tôt cependant un
prince thann il y avait un étudiant pas
comme les autres
cet étudiant était un homme d'exception
ou du moins le personnage incarné par
russell crowe dans le film un homme
d'exception à savoir le presque médaille
fields et prix nobel d'économie john
nash et comme on l'a vu dans des
épisodes précédents
nash n'avait pas froid aux yeux un an
après avoir plus rendez vous avec
einstein nash n'hésita pas à prendre
rendez vous avec le grand volume 1
pour lui parler de défaillance majeure
de sa théorie des jeux selon la légende
quant à lui présenta le désormais très
célèbre théorème de nage de la théorie
des jeux von neumann lui a répondu
sèchement mais ces trials c'est juste un
terrain du pont fixe
or en effet le terrible de 9 en théorie
les jeux et pas le plus sophistiqué de
tout l'été aurait donc j'irai quand même
pas jusqu'à dire qu'il est trivial mais
ce qui fut révolutionnaire n'est pas
tout à fait le terreau homme des neiges
ce qui fut révolutionnaire sais que nash
compris ce que beaucoup d'entre nous
semble oublier à savoir le fait que la
plupart des jeux notamment en économie
ne sont pas à somme cette remarque peut
paraître très contre intuitive après
tout la possession de l'argent est un
jeu à somme nulle
si je donne un euro à quelqu'un je perds
un euro et cette personne gagne 1 euro
autrement dit dans toute transaction
financière
ce que les uns gagnent est égal à ce que
les autres perdent
et même lorsqu'une institution créer de
la monnaie si on considère que ce qui
importe est la fraction de toute la
monnaie que chacun possède cette
création monétaire se fait du coup
forcément aux dépens de ceux qui avaient
déjà beaucoup de monnaie en poche du
couvent en oman s'est sentis obligés
d'introduire des joueurs fictif pour
balancer les comptes et pour s'assurer
que ces jeux étaient bien des jeux à
sommes nulles génie de nage flux de
cendres compte qu'il s'agissait là d'un
artefact non seulement inutile mais qui
passaient aussi et surtout sous silence
un aspect beaucoup plus réaliste des
interactions humaines les jeux en
général ne sont pas à somme nulle
le gagnant gagnant ce n'est pas qu'un
bullshit et de cadres parisiens
en général il peut exister des stratégie
gagnant gagnant notamment par opposition
à des stratégies qui serait plutôt
perdant perdant
nash avait sans doute penser à la guerre
froide qui s'annonçait entre les états
unis et l'urss une guerre
thermonucléaire serait alors clairement
perdants car dans par opposition
si aucune des superpuissances de
préparer la guerre on aurait une
situation bien bien enfin si l'une des
superpuissances attaque l'autre sans que
l'autre niçois préparer l'issue serait
alors un gagnant morts en fait le jeu
était un peu plus compliqué que ça
puisque les deux superpuissances peuvent
aussi se préparer à la guerre sans
jamais la déclencher si les deux
superpuissances font ceci on se retrouve
dans une situation neutre neutre mais
surtout chaque super puissance pourra
exercer des pressions sur l'autre si
l'autre ne s'est pas préparé à la guerre
qui plus est si une super puissance se
fait attaquer par l'autre certes elle
subira de lourdes pertes
mais elle pourra infliger de sévères
dégâts à l'autre avant de disparaître
bon jusque là la modélisation et pas
suffisamment mathématiques pour conages
puissent l'étudier
l'étape suivante de nage vous
d'appliquer la théorie de l'utilité
espérer de vollmann morgenstern nage
remplaça les gagnants perdants mort
neutre bien et malmené par des nombres
qui reflète les utilités des deux camps
de façon générale pour nage dans un jeu
il y a des joueurs qui interagissent
chaque joueur doit choisir une action et
de façon cruciale l'utilité d'un joueur
dépend des actions de tous les joueurs
alors faut naumann aurait rajouté que
peu importe les actions des différents
joueurs
la somme des utilités des joueurs serait
forcément égal à zéro ménages se rendit
compte que l'utilité n'est ni de
l'argent ni de l'énergie il n'y a en
général pas de conservation de l'utilité
le modèle de nash est déjà intéressant
en lui-même mais le génie de nash n'est
pas ce modèle
le génie de nashville introduire le
concept d' équilibre de nash enfin lâche
lui il ya juste appeler ça équilibre ce
sont les théoriciens des jeux et les
économistes modernes qui l'appelle
désormais équilibre de nage quoi qu'il
en soit ce concept est subtil et
révolutionnaire un équilibre de najet
une issue du jeu
tel que sachant ce que les autres
joueurs ont fait aucun joueur n'aura pu
faire mieux pour lui et selon lui par
exemple dans le cas du jeu dont on vient
de parler la situation neutre neutre est
un équilibre de nage en effet sachant
que l'urss s'est préparé à la guerre
mais n'attaque pas les états unis
peuvent soit attaqué ce se préparer sans
attaquer soit ne pas se préparer à la
guerre dans le premier cas les états
unis essuie de sévères dégâts dans le
troisième cas ils se font extorqué la
meilleure stratégie des états unis pour
eux et selon eux est donc celle qui
conduit à la situation
neutre neutre de la même manière l'urss
n'aurait pas pu faire mieux pour eux et
selon peut se préparer sans attaquer et
est leur meilleure stratégie sachant que
les etats-unis se préparer sans attaquer
na je suis aussi le génie de prouver
l'omniprésence des équilibres de dash ou
plus précisément éprouve acte où je
finis possède un équilibre de nash mixte
bon comme vous en doutez il ya des
détails techniques derrière tout ça et
on y reviendra dans le prochain épisode
ce sur quoi j'aimerais finir c'est la
bizarrerie de l'équilibré de nash qui
hantent les économistes à savoir un
équilibre d'une tâche peut très bien
être une stratégie perdante perdante en
particulier dans le jeu que l'on vient
de voir il y à un autre équilibre de
nash à savoir le cas où les deux
superpuissances s'attaquent mutuellement
en effet sachant que les etats-unis les
ont attaqués l'urss n'a pas mieux à
faire que d'attaquer les états unis à
leur tour
en effet ils ne perdent rien par rapport
au cas où ils ne font que réagir à
l'attaqué des américains et la stratégie
ou ne font que subir attaque est
clairement la pire de toutes
ce raisonnement est bien sûr identique
si on inverse le rôle des us et de
l'urss et de façon contre intuitif
d'après la théorie des jeux le cas où
les us et l'urss détruisent mutuellement
n'est en fait rien d'irrationnel
d'après notre modèle
il s'agit même de l'une des deux issues
rationnelle de cette guerre alors bien
sûr dans le cas d'une destruction
mutuelle on a tous envie de dire qu'ils
auraient tellement mieux fait de ne pas
faire la guerre du tout mais il faut
bien garder en tête que les us ne
peuvent pas choisir la stratégie de
l'urss et l'urss ne peut pas choisir les
stratégies des us chaque pays ne peut
contrôler que sa stratégie
chaque pays va devoir faire ce qui est
bien pour lui et selon lui étant donné
ce qu'il croit que l'autre pays fera et
en pratique c'est bien souvent comme ça
que fonctionnent les interactions
humaines
bien souvent on sait qu'il va être
difficile de changer le comportement de
l'autre du coup il vaut sans doute mieux
l'anticiper et de faire ce qui est bien
pour nous selon nous étant donné ce que
l'on croit que l'autre fera si tel est
le cas en partie les gens n'arrivent pas
à coopérer alors l'issue des
interactions ne sera pas forcément
gagnante gagnante elle sera un équilibre
de nash on a parlé des actions de vos
nomades morgenstern et de paradoxes
daley du coup j'ai coupé un peu les
chiffres que je suis à marrakech en ce
moment ça serait sympa d'avoir quelques
images du maroc
donc j'ai compris les chiffres et vous
avez été 169 pas répondre en b2b donc en
fait la majorité d'entre vous sont assez
consistant en tout cas sur cet exemple
là vous avez été quand même 116 à dire 1
à 2 p ce que représente 35%
vous avez été aussi 34 et puis il ya 15
ans les corneilles d'une corde la
cuisson qui font figure d'exception et
qu'ils ont dit un bep dehors 35 qui ont
dit à 2-2 à l'occasion de tous est de
tout ça c'est que vous êtes un
échantillon très biaisée de la
population forcément vous êtes les gens
cool et gens les plus rationnels qui
font gaffe à ce qu'ils disent et à ceux
qui préfèrent visiblement valentin
mercier nous demande me demande quels
sont les chaînes youtube pertinentes
notamment cette brune et à la paresse
dans pas mal de mes vidéos va regarder
les descriptions il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de choses dans les descriptions toutes
les infos sont dedans et du coup je vous
invite vraiment un clic et surtout ses
liens et à les découvrir ce que les
autres youtuber fond de génial guillaume
le cas mais benoît douane nous demande
si la transitivité est vraiment quelque
chose
axiome qui devrait vraiment être parmi
les actions de bonne manne dans venture
de scapa des phénomènes ou par exemple
préféré à abb assez dans le chocolat
vanille a gagné 1,13 à fraises au
chocolat la réponse est oui c'est
possible mais ça veut aussi dire que
un commerçants véreux pour être capable
de vous extorquer vous proposant pour un
centime de vous auprès des du chocolat à
la vanille puis pour un autre sentiment
que vous offrez des deux
la vanille à la presse qui pour un autre
sentiment que vous avez d après au
chocolat et puis continue ainsi de suite
et ainsi vous extorquer de l'argent donc
l'absence de productivité plus tôt c'est
une instance hymne au cas où vous pouvez
vous faire extorquer cela parfois que
c'est considérer irrationnel que de ne
pas satisfaire les axiomes de vollmann
morgenstern parties de passer dans la
prochaine vidéo sept vols c'est un
retour sur les questions de vidéos
précédentes
raphaël théry nous demande si il ya un
lien entre la vidéo précédente et le
fait notamment de la perception de
censier
les probabilités qu'il a décrites très
bien écrite séance étonnante dans cette
vidéo
ben oui carrément et d'ailleurs dans la
vidéo société applique très bien qu'on a
une mauvaise perception notamment des
faibles probabilités mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été encore observées
dans les données expérimentales nom et
ses anciens empirique psychologie
expérimentale mais oui très généralement
il semble qu'on surestime largement les
très faible probabilité est typiquement
la probabilité qu'un avion se pose en
vol ou sais pas pourquoi
d'accord la probabilité qu'une voiture
sans conducteur n'est pas d'accident est
un accident
cette probabilité elle est nulle du coup
on se dit qu'elle doit être prendre mais
en fait il est très très petit où pareil
pour le loto et tout ça you'll nous dit
qu'il a apparemment j'imagine tournée
100 millions de simulation et au bout de
100 millions de simulation du jeu du
paradoxe de prêter à rebours il n'a
récolté que 63 euros se montre que la
variance de ce jeu est énorme fête de la
variance ayant fini tout comme
l'espérance dont on n'atteindra jamais
en moyenne l'espérance avec des données
bancaires puisque façon que jamais
atteindre l'infini en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que globalement la
probabilité de gagner au moins
un million d'euros ou une quantité x
d'euros en général va être inférieure à
un mois sur x c'est ça donc si vous la
praille était de gagner un million et
plus petites sont le coeur un mois un
sur un million
il faut répéter des millions de fois
pour espérer gagner quelque chose qui
dépasse un million de truc c'est que dès
que ça dépasse un million parce qu'on
sait que ce soit une très très grande
quantité
là c'est de là que vient le paradoxe de
saint pétersbourg plus généralement en
fait y'a pas trop c'est très risqué de
mettre beaucoup d'argent dans ce
paradoxe puisque la probabilité de
gagner décroît très très très rapidement
dès qu'on regarde les gains potentiels
assez grand dia note 001 nous demande si
elle est capable possible d'avoir un
modèle du fonctionnement humain qui
inclut qui intègre le fait que nos
capacités cognitives sont limitées la
réponse est oui j à des modèles qu en
tout cas je vais rencontrer notamment
j'avais un ancien collègue qui
travaillait sur un modèle dit de
rationalité limitée ou en fait ceux qui
avouent regarder c'était parce qu il
affirmé dans ses modalités que notre
capacité à engranger de l'information ce
qui mesure avec la théorie de
l'information de shannon
et en fait limitée du coup la prise de
décision est une prise de décision avec
une capacité de capture des informations
limitées
c'est seulement parce que c'est en fait
un modèle qui était qui est un ami à moi
enfin collègues et moi qui travaillais
dessus et qu'ils avaient essayé de
sortir ce modèle pour expliquer quelle
est la meilleure façon de d'avoir des
satellites qui réfléchissent et à chaque
fois qu'ils doivent communiquer ils
doivent enlever des signaux qu'il ya un
coup ou signal est envoyé que peut
escompter monde aux piques envoyées et
du couffo optimisée à la fois et ray
satellites ont dans leur processus de
l'information aussi dans le choix de
ceux qui vont envoyer comme information
est ce pour ça que ce modèle de
de rationalité limitée qui a été
développé dans cet objectif et ce qui me
rend c'est que ça des applications enfin
s'intéresse à mal les psychologues
d'après ce qu'il m'a dit je ne fais pas
beaucoup plus j'espère que vous avez
aimé cette vidéo à présent on va
stresser équipe de nage avec un top 10
des jeux de la théorie des jeux
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
le lac est allé commentaires le partage
et pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes
merci au type heures pour lord ans et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois et si l'un décide de voler et
l'autre de partager le voleur prend tout
le magot et le partage heures par les
mamies
[Musique]
et comme pour le dilemme du prisonnier
c'est un jeu à somme non constante
la solution collaborative et globalement
la meilleure mais la trahison est
tentante et risque de mener à la pire
solution